six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's try the
six one six area code caller from six
one six tell us who you are and go right
ahead
hey but this is derek from grandpa to
Michigan
okay go ahead Derek yeah I hope you have
your crystal ball available because I'm
going to ask for some prognostication
okay um so the hard right identifies
with Trump very much these days you know
they're they're Mogga hats and it's all
Trump Trump Trump but I see this as sort
of like the same population of people
sort of just morphing into a new
identity I mean in the 90s it was all
about Pat Robertson New World Order
rapture bah bah bah then in the 2000s it
was a tea party tea party where do you
think this group is going to go after
Trump as relevant I mean how long do you
think they're going to hold on to trump
as an identity I think that that last
part is less important I think the first
part is the really interesting one which
is what's the direction it will go next
and I think it is the total
normalization of bold proud ignorant as
a legitimate political ideology and
that's what Trump if Trump has
legitimized anything more sort of
acutely than a previous Republican it is
this sort of defense of I don't know
anything I don't tell the truth I I
don't behave I can't be trusted
and that's okay because I've convinced
people that I'm gonna fix how they're
being treated on trade or whatever else
right and I think that that is the most
dangerous thing in the movement that
Donald Trump has catalyzed because it
actually so previously there were three
like really distinct lines of
republicanism so to speak you had the
sort of Mitt Romney type low tax semi
moderate on social issues although
certainly not progressive business
conservatives you had the very very
small government types like the
libertarian minded government is the
problem types and then he had the
ideological religious conservatives and
they had overlaps but there were also
pretty significant points of
disagreement
they still disagree but the lines have
been blurred significantly with these
groups where they all have accepted the
overarching philosophy of Trump to the
extent that it exists which is that it's
great to not know anything it's great to
be clueless about politics it's great to
treat people poorly because I guess that
identifies you as the common guy but
he's gonna protect the status that I
believe that I might lose if immigrants
or Democrats or Obama are allowed to
make decisions so I think that that is
going to be the lasting effect of the
Trump presidency
yeah anti an anti intellectualism has
been you know have had a long thread in
American history for sure yep and it's
definitely cyclical but it is rearing
its head right now in a way that is
shocking and scary especially given the
access to information that we have at
our fingertips with our phones no doubt
no doubt
thank you so much for the call I
appreciate it thanks take care